taking a few calls because we had a
last-minute guest cancellation at 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 let's try the 9 1 9 area
code who's calling today from 9 1 9 oh
hi I mean that is you okay um big fan of
show I listen a lot and I've been
following the campaign of Andrew yang
very closely even though I may have the
bird ability in the primary Oh God
one of the selling points and uses for
the API is the savings of replacing
other welfare programs with the ubi
and I saw your interview know you had
skepticism about that part of it in
trying to raise all ships and I wonder
how do you think that will affect the
funding for it what do you what will
affect the funding for what if if
instead of replacing the welfare
programs keeping those because he uses
the replacement of those programs with
opting in as a selling point for it
right yeah so here's the thing I said
before if you replace a thousand dollars
in welfare benefits with a thousand
dollars in you be I the person who ends
up with a thousand dollars a month is
not better off you reduce infrastructure
and sort of bureaucracy so it's a
cheaper program for the government to
administer but you're not really raising
anybody out of poverty for example now
what andrew yang argues is that right
now if you get a thousand dollars in
welfare benefits that are means-tested
number one you are disincentive eyes
from going out and doing something even
remotely productive because you don't
want to lose the thousand dollars in
welfare benefits that you get and that
number to the thousand dollars in
means-tested welfare benefits are
stigmatized by society because people
make judgments about others who are
receiving welfare benefits there's no
doubt about that so what andrew yang
says yes you're replacing a thousand
dollars with a thousand dollars but you
are freeing someone to do stuff to make
money in addition to the thousand and
you're distinct which is a really good
thing for them psychologically I agree
but I still am against you be
that merely replaces all of those
welfare programs however what I am okay
with is if the thousand dollars in ubi
combined with whatever else you're doing
does put you above a threshold where you
no longer qualify for something like
food stamps or whatever else okay then
we're actually talking about someone
whose standard of living has become such
that they are sort of moving up but the
idea of just dollar for dollar replacing
welfare benefits with ubi that's not how
I would do it and I've told Andrew yang
personally that I don't that's not the
way I would do it okay thank you and I
have another really quick question is
that you go live a lot on the show and
with that and the pre-recording how do
you deal with the nerves of that because
it is live and like there's I guess some
form of pressure with that sorry with
that how do I deal with the pressure of
what being live when I do a live stream
on you how would ya like do you get any
like pre-show oh no no no no I don't
when I do like national TV appearances I
still get a little nervous but just
doing the show or from our studio it I
don't get nervous about that anymore oh
okay thank you very much like I said big
fan of the show all right thank you very
much appreciate the call